i don't know how they're going to wrap
this whole thing up or even if they're
going to or this will go into a season
two or maybe we'll even see moonlight
into a movie i hope they do that but it
is this is one hell of a journey hey
everyone what is going on we're here to
talk about moon knight that's right the
all new disney plus marvel studio series
launching on march 30th i have seen the
first four episodes i'm not going to
spoil it for you but i will give you my
top line thoughts what i liked what i
didn't like about the performances a
little bit about the story just so
enough so you have an understanding when
you go into it what to expect
and all that great stuff so with that
let's let's talk about moon night um
moon knight as a marvel comics character
i mean most of you probably never heard
of him i read marvel comics growing up i
didn't even know about moon knight he's
not an a grade character b grade
character i would say c to d grade
character some people categorize him as
a poor man's batman but i wouldn't
necessarily say that there are some
similarities i guess you could say but
no it's very very different um but i
would say this character does remind me
a little bit as it is in the series at
least of ghost rider
uh in the aspect of you know how johnny
blaze had to sell his soul to the devil
then he turned into ghost rider to you
know complete some tasks that he needed
to do
that kind of correlates with moon knight
in some way of course
instead of one person johnny blaze you
have now multiple personalities as in
steven grant and mark spector
and them dealing with themselves and of
course then moon knight comes into play
so there is a lot of characters in this
show maybe not a lot of actors but
there's a lot of characters
and the first episode deals a lot with
that it deals a lot with the multiple
personality disorder to help the
audience understand what stephen grant
goes through his trials as tribulations
living this life he's secluded he feels
like he's alone
you know and trying to just navigate the
world feeling this way which is
fascinating and it's it's a really
awesome way to that way that marvel and
disney has approached this this content
because it really is unique very very
unique but if you're going into this
expecting a superhero series you may be
slightly disappointed because i did with
looking at the trailers i thought this
was going to be like a superhero series
of course we learn about you know how he
becomes moon knight etcetera etcetera at
least that's what i thought then he goes
and he fights the bad guys or the
creatures but
it's not necessarily that it deals with
the psychosis
of
steven grant mark spector a lot of the
time
then after the first episode you get a
little bit more of that a little bit
aspects of understanding moon knight a
little bit more then it changes
directions and going into
an adventure show like the mummy uh
1990s and even the most you know the
later 2000s version with tom cruise
there's elements of that that are right
there smack in your face something maybe
like an indiana jones in some ways as
well so you have this sort of adventure
ride that it takes you on which is great
and it's fun and exciting and it adds a
little bit of lightness to the show
because the first episode is quite heavy
it is quite heavy in a lot of ways and
for some of you may be going do i really
want to invest this time in the show but
i would say yes do so
because it takes you on this journey and
then episode four just completely just
flips everything or you think it does i
don't know because i have not seen
episode five yet but it is it's one of
those moments when you're like
mind blown what just happened here
and then all the things that you were
maybe frustrated about in episodes one
two and three
made sense
in episode four
and that's where the show gets very
interesting is because it goes on this
adventure series egyptian mythology all
that great stuff finding this mcguffin
and then
along the way things just don't make
complete sense you're going to go yeah i
get we're living in this creative
licensed world through marvel studios of
course and it's a marvel character and
it's a comic book series but
the personalities are so extreme and
they're so different like how could
anybody live a life like this how could
it make any sense
and the show does address that it does
address that and that was one of my
frustrations and that's why when i say
setting the expectations the beginning
of this video the top line things i
didn't like so much or what i liked
those are the things i didn't like so
much because it didn't make sense to me
but i would say stick with this show
because it does make sense when it comes
to episode four so keep that in mind
okay and i get why disney gave us the
episodes to watch in advance so we could
at least let you guys know that there is
a journey here it may not all make sense
right now but it does make sense or at
least tries to make sense of it but now
we're going to talk a little bit about
the performances in this
oscar isaac if he does not get an emmy
award for this series i don't know
what's wrong with the emmys
this
is a phenomenal performance i got to
tell you this could be
the best performance we have seen on any
disney plus series thus far
my mind was blown my jaw dropped at what
he was doing with these characters
uh i mean i've been a fan of his for
quite some time this brought my fan
level up to here uneffing believable
what you see out of this ethan hawk
awesome he plays a sort of an
evangelistic character who goes along
this journey finding this mcguffin as
well for his own particular reasons
and he also has some ties to moon knight
which is interesting and this kind of
the way they've kind of built this world
this uh
around moon night is fascinating and
it's it's refreshing because i think
we've seen so much related to the
previous marvel films with us you know
thus far and they're all kind of tied in
it is refreshing to see something kind
of very different from this and and and
i can see why both of these actors who
are
some of the best actors in cinema take
on rules like this for a limited series
or at least i wouldn't say limited
series but a series for disney plus is
because
these are meaty roles for characters
for character development any actor
who's in this series is going to love
having a role in this because the
directors the writers they've just
knocked it out of the park in that
regard we also got to talk about me
calamawi in this now she's an egyptian
actress in this and i believe she's a
relatively new actress
she really is
a pinnacle character in this she's not
the damsel in distress but she does
remind me a lot of rachel vice's
character in the mummy she has a lot of
those personality traits in some ways
not as comical
but in some aspects she does but also
some of the heroines that we've seen in
the indiana jones films she has a lot of
that as well so she's a very big part of
the series great chemistry with oscar
isaac um
you're gonna really enjoy it and i like
how they've implemented her into the
show especially with the various
different personalities in moon knight
what does she know what does does she
not know how does she deal with these
things it's awesome to watch and i think
that's what i really liked about this
series more than anything was the
writing the attention the detail for the
small these small moments that you
captured this because when you're
dealing with multiple personalities
character like moon knight and then
you're dealing with you know this
egyptian mythology this macguffin and
all that great stuff you can get lost in
this series very easily but the way that
they've sort of
paced it as such that you don't get lost
if you just kind of pay attention but
these are shows that you're not going to
want to fall asleep on you miss a couple
minutes you're going to want to go back
and rewatch it again because every
moment means something in this
and that's what's fascinating it kind of
reminds me of an m night shyamalan movie
as well because where he really kind of
takes you on this journey every moment
every look
every sentence means something for
something somewhere down the road and
that's what the series does with moon
knight i don't know if this show is for
kids necessarily i think that this
series
it reminds me a lot of the netflix kind
of series the netflix marvel series very
adult oriented it's not as graphic but
it is violent at times quite more
violent than i thought it was going to
be and graphic sometimes as well i'm
going to say if you're a parent you have
kids and you're thinking this can be
another superhero tv series you may want
to sit and watch this with them i would
say anyone any child younger than 10
maybe wait a little bit but if they're
like a young teenager or whatever i
think it'll be fine for them but i just
want to put things in perspective
because the way the marketing kind of
comes off in some ways it looks like
it's this guy just you know dressed in
white with a cape and he's going out
there fighting creatures and saving the
day and it's not that kind of series
whatsoever there's a lot more involved
in this um but besides that i mean
that's pretty much it i mean a lot of
the issues that i had with the the the
story development and the characters
didn't make sense to me and i was kind
of documented as i was watching each
episode
because
it kind of went to the extremes but then
when you go to episode four it kind of
explains why all that happened in some
way or at least it leads you on to going
i cannot wait to see episode five
because there's only two episodes left
after this and i'm going
i don't know how they're gonna wrap this
whole thing up or even if they're going
toward this will go into a season two or
maybe we'll even see moonlight into a
movie i hope they do that but
it is this is one hell of a journey this
is a ride that you're going to enjoy but
you do need to pace yourself and do
watch all the episodes you already get
frustrated do not be just follow through
with it because once you do you're gonna
be really happy anyway those are my
thoughts on moon knight let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
any questions you have without me
spoiling it for you i'll try to answer
them for you in the comment section
below with that subscribe to the channel
like this video follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube be safe out
there and i'll chat to you soon take
care
you